our next guests took their most awkward
teenage moments from the early 2000s and
then turned it into a hit show on hulu
called penn 15.
maya and anna are just two gals not
unlike many of us who found a way to
turn those teenage awkward years into
this extraordinary show i thought a
fitting way
to display my love and admiration of
these women
were to
get into my own inner awkward young girl
who is the best representation of how i
felt growing up and we wrote a character
her name is josie grossi
and she's about to interview
uh maya and anna of penn 15. please
enjoy this very very special segment
okay i'm josie gellard i'm gonna bring
out two best friends who have agreed to
do an interview with me for our paper
the south glen south gazette
please welcome to my chat room
maya ishii peters and anna cohn
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much
oh my god thank you for having us
oh my god
i'm like 15 now and you guys are
13 14 13. yeah but like yeah i love your
dress
thank you amazing so how did you guys
like meet how did the world bring you
two together yeah it was god
um
i like to say we met when we were born
but it was not that case it was actually
a talent show and like we got placed
together to dance and it was to salt and
pepper and like that's what we did and
then we've been best friends ever since
and her moves are incredible
no 100
when i saw her for the first time do the
moves
i was like i can't keep up
oh my god i like do the worm oh yes
she's amazing okay
yes
i sometimes i like to do um i i should
do it off the carpet because i can see
where this is going like
i like
and then
i also really like this one
that's very good that is very good and
all sometimes if there's a guy around
i'll just be like this at first and then
i'll go like this
like this
[Applause]
that's um
you've definitely done that before yeah
um
the truth is
is i i haven't actually
um
sorry that's okay you know i'm just
gonna say it i really want to kiss
someone i really really really i it's
like it's time because you haven't yet
okay yeah have you
i yeah
yeah but it's always different like the
first time it was really bad
i just wasn't expecting the tongue
basically
i just thought it would be lips and then
knew what it did well it was like an
alien like it went down it went like
this
and so not how it's supposed to i don't
think so that's not what i wanted but
like for me i didn't have like a kiss
kiss but like it was on
my chin and like he like made out with
my chin and stuff
okay i'm gonna admit something here like
i actually have um kissed a lot
but it's i know i knew it well it's like
pillows yeah and yeah yeah and like
is there like an inanimate object that
you ever make out with because that's
sort of i'm like i'm training myself for
the big game
and i feel like in sports nobody walks
out on that court and they're like i've
never done this before
so yeah like i
like
a knob
could that work this one's great really
yeah
do you prefer prefer knobs
to make out with or mirrors
i like both i like knobs
do you think that like frosted tips on a
boy are hot or not
hot
not
okay yeah not not oh my god i am totally
with my i
don't like that i'm like what did you do
to yourself you like a porcupine with
like like ice on top like it's weird i'm
like god you're a human cupcake why all
the frosting yeah
no i know that is what i think
i yeah the wrong word by mistake okay
i actually think if we're all
friends that we're going to be a lot
stronger together because then we'll be
unstoppable yeah and i just know
something about
like girls
crazy
i've like i just have seen that the
power of three girls can be extremely
successful
yeah yeah we've had that experience yeah
the power of girls yes you really can't
kick down a tripod it's scientifically
sound i did my god so you guys let's be
like this forever then like the three of
us like always holding hands
structurally sound like forever they
make stools in like denmark and
copenhagen with three legs wow
i know you know what i think this is
gonna make a really great piece for the
paper
thanks for having us so much for having
us let's go and tell everybody how like
being best friends is pretty much
everything okay okay i love you i love
you so much yeah also maybe lady after
the mall we can like totally like get
some knobs and pillows and mirrors and i
don't know
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much in case you
want to stay up all night thank you yes
definitely i got really crazy with this
wow all right let's go okay bye all
right
the interview is over okay all right
okay
i think we should hit wet seal first
okay
[Music]
you